Julian wants to know would either of you
ever go hunting my answer is very simple
if I needed to go hunting in order to
feed myself I would go hunting otherwise
the answer is no I have no interest in
killing animals either for optional meat
consumption or for sport right I mean if
you're off in the wilderness somewhere
you choose to live off the grid or maybe
you're born to a tribe that hunts to
survive right totally fair game that's
out of necessity you have the right to
to live and even if that means to kill
other beings to do so you can do that
but the fact that we live in a civilized
society where most of us are so close to
the grocery store makes hunting
completely unnecessary at this point
yeah I would not I would not do it at
Brian where you identify you agreeing
with us or disagree
all right well listen that this would be
you would hunt for sport well I don't
know that you need to but I think it's a
fine argument to make if it resonates
with you
bright edit Brian's kind of I don't I
don't know if yeah but Brian okay anyway
but I think we're both would any of us
go hunting no given where we live in
society would that be open the Brian
saying maybe hunting is the sport where
the other team doesn't even know that
you're playing yes that's true that's
true especially when it's hibernating
bears as was recently legalized in
Alaska which I've been told doesn't mean
literally bears that are in the sleeping
process but during hibernation season it
just seems so rude to me it's like these
beer and other animals who just doing
their own thing and you have to
needlessly kill them for your own
entertainment that's like why would
someone do that as far as I go is I went
to a shooting range and shot a few guns
and it didn't really do much for me and
yeah that's about it shooting is totally
fine yeah now what about like bow and
arrow hunting do you think that that is
more more fair no the animals okay so
sometimes hunters will be killed
themselves and I think you know I can't
really express too much sympathy for the
animals fight back yeah I mean like if
you're going to put yourself in that
position sometimes that can happen you
know I talk to disagree with that yeah
agree with that all right so listen
unless I needed to serve I needed the
food to survive no I would not go
hunting you're not just going to do it
like Donald Trump's sons no I will not
do that
especially not elephants but who wants
to kill an elephant these days given
what we know about elephants and the
ivory trade and all that stuff you
wouldn't kill an elephant right Bryan
now okay good and you wouldn't you
wouldn't kill a what you wouldn't kill a
whale no good what about a killer whale
well that's a euphemism I saw by the way
in Vermont over the week I went to IMAX
and saw a great documentary about
humpback whales and we're completely off
topic no hunting for me great bonus show
for you today